CAPITAL ONE ARENA.
MAKING THEIR LONE TEAM METIT ONO
FEHERVARY.
HE'LL CREWS NE THE FIVE
MINUTE MARK OF THE
CORNER.
PASS SAVE DEMKO.
IN A HURRY AND FORE
CHECK TEP UP.
THIS IS PUT OUT BESSER LOOKING .
THAT WILL CHASE HUGHES ANDSAVE O
6'3" IN THE CAGE.
WAITING FOR JT DOWN THE  THEIR .
SCHULTZ AND A BEAUTIFUL PASS.
HE'S HIT THE WHEEL HOUSE EVERY
TIME TO
THAT PROMISES TO BE AN
INTERESTING RATE OVER THE
REMAINING TIMEA SOFT SPOT BETWE
TOP OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCE AND WILL
WERE HAVING DEFENSIVE ISSUES.
THEY'VE BEEN BUTTONED UP BETTER
COMING OUT.
THERE'S THE SHOT.
IN THE SECOND.
BODY BY TOM WILSON.
7-4-2. ONE GOALIE GOT BECAUSE O
SAMSONOV MADE TWO STEPS THERE
ASIT'SCATCH.
OVECHKIN TWO ON ONE.
FIRES.
ANOTHER BEAUTY FROM THE
TOWERING NETONONWORKED THE POWE.
HATHAWAY IN THE HE H H
BROTHERS.
TERRY MURRAY THE ANSWER.
>> WE PLAYED AGAOTHER
THE QUICK PASSING  THE THIRD.
>> GOING TO
FINISH OFF WITH 57.2 TRYING TO .
NICE PLAY DOWN LOW FROM